as an Iranian Refugee who grew up in
rural East Tennessee and someone who
studied lived and worked in over 30
countries I thought I knew how to
navigate across cultures and
languages I was wrong there I was day
one of business school getting my
bearings and hearing an alien language
it wasn't English French or my native
Persian it was a bullia Bas of languages
jargon from across the organizational
Multiverse the corporate world the
nonprofit sphere International
Development and the public sector it was
weird in business school I thought I'd
learn about leadership styles what I
found were leadership languages and I
learned that by becoming conversent in
in these languages that I could
communicate with and contribute to all
of these
worlds so how does one become
multilingual here's my story in college
I went to West Africa to study micro
finance and economic empowerment seeing
a large Public Health need I co-founded
and led a nonprofit collecting medical
supplies and
money we saw what Collective action
could yield and we were creative with
our advocacy and our fundraising with
campaigns like Band-Aids for
benine along the way I studied different
leadership styles autocratic Democratic
Laz Fair servant collaborative
transformational and more I read books
attended trainings and I even had the
privilege to study with some of the
greats and to work with General col po
and Dr Maya
Angelou after all of this I became
convinced that there's no best type of
leadership so many of us just default to
one style or another similar to how
we're born with our native
tongue but this default style doesn't
work in every
situation many leaders obsess over
leadership style when really they just
need to get over
themselves sorry leader it's not about
you what's more useful is to adapt and
personalize your leadership to be the
leader the situation and the people
involved
need it's not so much style as language
the living vernacular of each discreet
community and
culture the successful leader will
aspire to be multilingual to speak
fluently with all groups and to
translate among
them in 2012 while working at the idar
network I was one of the sponsors of a
two-year study of 12 impact investing
funds one of the ahas of this project
was that the most successful funds were
those led by multilingual leaders people
that could communicate across the
corporate nonprofit philanthropic and
public policy
perspectives these leaders also made
sure that others on their team were
multilingual H this came to me as a bit
of a surprise I expected the secret
sauce to be in sophisticated Financial
modeling or some other type of complex
analysis according to this study the
multilingual leader will describe their
work as being unremittingly financially
driven business speak moving the needle
on social and environmental challenges
nonprofit and philanthropic speak while
addressing systemic market failures
public policy speak the study further
found the need to be conversent into
four industry languages those a finance
nonprofit Prof government and
International Development the
multilingual
leader was something that seemed very
familiar to me this really rang true
based on my own experience of patchworks
across these sectors and it took me back
to that first weird day in business
school now that we've described the how
let us turn to the what where should
leaders Focus
I will modestly propose three topics
that cut across issues and together
we'll double click on one of
them data climate
power how each of these sectors measure
the impact and even the timing the tempo
and the tools that they use for each
could not be more
different say
you're the private sector at one end you
have accounting on a daily a weekly a
monthly and quarterly increments the
public sector you're working on
multi-year Election Cycles the nonprofit
and philanthropic sector well you may
give yourself 15 years or even a
generation to reach a
goal yet all of these sectors must come
together to reach these
outcomes to make it real let's look
together about how these sectors can
come together to address power with the
focus on gender equality
say you're a public sector leader you
have the unique ability to create Equity
a Level Playing Field so everyone has a
fair shot you can create regulations and
incentives to increase the use of gender
data you can set goals for women on
boards and in public office you can
practice gender budgeting and you can
mandate paid
care say you're a leader in the business
sector you can design products and
services that unleash the economic power
of the female customer you can fortify
and diversify your supply chain with
women-owned businesses and you can
invest in your female Talent Pipeline
with pay equity and Leadership
opportunities so that your corporate
decisions are more
inclusive or maybe you work in
philanthropy or International
Development
you can help remove the barriers whether
formal or informal that influence how
power is
distributed you can fund the research
and training that both the public and
the private sector need to do their part
you can fund campaigns and Grassroots
efforts that influence social and
cultural norms and you can help get
women in decision-making roles in their
households in their community ities in
their countries and in
economies the multilingual leader can be
conversent and use the languages of all
of these sectors to identify the root
causes and then collaborate together to
find the solutions to these complex
issues so here is over 20 years of
experience distilled into one
sentence don't fr
over your leadership styles focus on
your leadership
languages so over to you leader Which
languages are you going to learn next
thank
[Applause]
you